[Music]
joe
how many times do you think you have
flown into the narita
airport in japan tan well that's a lot a
lot of times
that's a lot wow not if your family is
there
and you want to see them alive all this
time did you know
because i didn't know but i'm curious if
you knew did you know
that there's a huge or not a huge
there's a farm
in the middle of the airport no yeah but
it's farm country
so it makes sense there's a actual farm
here
that has been in battles with the
airport
that's crazy you're wanting to like buy
it out or something the circle is what
the farm i think in the middle of all
right so there's air strips on both
sides
it actually goes around the farm one of
them how pissed is that farmer bro yeah
see look at this it goes around if this
was china they'd like get the [ __ ] out
of here man
and then they'd remove the farm
immediately well in japan they actually
have a lot of laws that protect farmers
and so that's the reason why they're
lucky they're not in china yeah this
family has been
fighting against like getting like
selling their property what about the
poor airline
well [ __ ] the airline it came actually
this farm has been there for over a
hundred years by three generations it's
been tended
by so how the runway perfectly goes
around i bet you at this point it's just
[ __ ] petty fighting too
it's like [ __ ] that airline [ __ ]
so the guy that's
that has taken over his dad so initially
it was the grandpa that started
the farm on this land and then the dad
took over
and then now he took over after his dad
passed
and so he's saying like this soil has
been tended to by three generations like
the food that he grows there it's like
organic vegetables and stuff
with airplane fuel like dusting yeah
that's
the the pollution and stuff they have
determined that the airport is not
affecting
the the quality
i know how do they determine that what
if he wants a farm more because he's
like man they've been growing
bigger since the planes have been flying
no they're coming in what do they grow
oh like just vegetables gasoline
tomatoes
no if it's like those ball and ass
grapes because you know they have like
80
grapes no it seems like it's it's just
really really humble
they got carrots and [ __ ] i feel like it
feels boring if it was vietnam they
would totally market it that way they'd
be like i got this gasoline
coffee just like our weasel poop coffee
makes it better oh
chemtrail cucumber is pretty good coming
in really nice
yeah well so he's saying that at this
point it's just
you know he doesn't it's not about the
money because he has been offered over
a million dollars for his land and
that's what's wrong with a lot of these
people it's never about the money and
then for him is just the the soil
that has been tended to for so long he's
like that top soil i can't just pick it
up and put it somewhere else and expect
it to
to work the same so for him that's the
main reason why he's like
[ __ ] you i'm keeping my farm you could
just pee and poo on your soil somewhere
that makes sense because
it takes time to um
your soil basically gives the taste to
your food
and then you have to work it a certain
way so
moving it i'm hearing i'm moving to a
whole new place
that he doesn't even know that's that
might be
that might be 30 plus years of work or
more because they did they had this for
100 yeah
oh the work yet because it's like it's
like seasoning something yeah so it's
it's like oh that makes a lot of [ __ ]
sense
but if you got if the airport pays them
like 20 mil or whatever
what the [ __ ] bro no search for him do
something else jet ski in okinawa or
some [ __ ]
he doesn't want i don't know the money i
want to grow [ __ ] carrots like my
granddaddy did
dude some people love farming like i
know somebody who loves farming
and it's like weird i like pretending
like i like farming you look like you
farm
like it's like a hobby for this person
they [ __ ] love it make sense it's
super
super strange to me i'm just like that
sounds so boring but you can't even have
a conversation on that farm
[ __ ] planes flying around it's like
this yeah
does this person have a lemon tree in a
pot i don't know good question
what is that oh he's talking about is it
joe it's it's not joe
it's a good question but joe's not a
farmer he is kind of a hobby farmer kind
of
i mean look at the hat he just picks
lemonade i was talking about nicki but
oh nice well our lemon tree is dead as
[ __ ] bro really is it
the last time i heard it was doing well
oh no bro there's a heat wave and it's
over for the lemon tree
r.i.p dude wow same with my grass
yeah our grass is dying too my garden is
doing pretty good
really yeah my tomato plants this tall i
already harvested some okra
my my zucchinis are like this big now
you're a [ __ ] farmer
aren't you about to be a farmer too well
not like that it's just i have a
partnership to a farm
growing some watermelon cool and some
strawberries i'm gonna make grow at home
shiitake kits
you could make mushrooms at home we love
shiitakes
yeah so this battle here um it's been
going on for
decades so his dad passed when he was 84
and so he ended up so the son he quit
his job
in the restaurant business and returned
to the farm to continue the fight
against the airport and
the local farmers around in his village
they were so sweet and they offered to
help him learn how to farm
since he had just taken over from after
just be so loud
every day he says that he gets used to
the sound it's not
like he just tunes it out now how does
he not have tinnitus or something from
like have his eardrums blown out every
day
i don't know like holy [ __ ] but then you
think about it too it's like whoa like
how do you
attend this farm all alone well he
doesn't he has
about 10 volunteers they're all flight
attendants
volunteers volunteers that come out and
help him with this farm because they
believe
in like the the integrity of having the
farm oh that's sweet
the average age of farmers in japan is
like
70 or some crazy yeah there's no
young farmers that are getting into it
so there's a
problem oh wait no that's bad then i
just thought they were doing it because
now they just want to stay busy
are they doing it for survival they
don't have young people don't want to
take it they don't want it
they don't want to work it's a lot of
work a lot of young people don't want to
do it because it's like no money i bet
also because the japanese way of doing
things is so traditional a lot of times
too
like i i watch like the little mini docs
of like japanese people
it's hard doing something that american
farmers might do but they
try to keep everything traditional all
the way through without the machinery
and i think young people are like [ __ ]
that yeah imagine
i mean not even just young people like
imagine working like 12 hours and that's
all you do
every seven days a week that's all you
[ __ ] do
and you only got like 20 grand extra a
month
generalizing here but you know what i
mean right it's it's it's pretty brutal
and then so a lot of these people are
like well i'd rather just get an
education and work for a company and go
to the city
i can have my own apartment you know i
don't have to work so much
i actually have a social life so then
young people don't want this farmer life
because it's like [ __ ] crazy
i think it's going to take a smart
person to revolutionize it and change it
because
like you said they're stuck in their old
ways or a rebel maybe not a smart person
maybe
more of a rebel what it's gonna take is
a chinese person
who thinks outside the box and they know
how to scale [ __ ] or it'll take
not enough farming and people are
[ __ ] starving and it's like yo
[ __ ] let's
let's get some machines in here and [ __ ]
off with this [ __ ] true yeah
and then make like produce more
affordable because it's super expensive
it depends on what you get out there
like the 70
grapes it's not normal but then produce
is pretty [ __ ] affordable
if you buy seasonal yeah i don't know
and the population is declining too so
it's like less food less people it's
fine
it balances out you know you just have
ghost towns and [ __ ] that's all it is
that's crazy yeah that's wild it's
what do you call it like in 50ish years
they're saying the population of japan
and korea
is gonna be like pretty much no people
left dude london
is rough too like apparently the uk is
having a rough time with birth rates too
a bunch of places are i feel like japan
uh all the these industries
japan has such like strong gatekeeping
for each of the industries you know
because you can't just like be a farmer
right or like or
be a master and whatever you always have
to apprentice for like 30 40 years
and then become a master and that's like
doing the [ __ ] work for like 20 years
of just like okay i'm gonna rake the
leaves
for like 10 years and or whatever so it
just seems like
i feel like those those that old way of
getting into these
like usually high esteem kind of jobs
it's it's
not everyone's like it take too long man
[ __ ]
i bet there's like um foreign farmers
like like chinese people or whatever
koreans coming into japan and they have
a more
entrepreneurial mindset less traditional
and they think about scaling and doing
things like
bigger so they're kind of coming in and
filling that void
of specialization can't feed a lot of
people
yeah so then they're coming in and
they're doing that so things are
definitely changing
are they like happy like hey we have
more of this and it's cheaper or they're
like that's not the way to do it
i don't think i think i think people
just kind of
hey that's affordable it's good enough
i'll buy it
now you have options right like instead
of just paying like
um craftsman level work that's hell
expensive and it's all like this now you
have options of like
walmart things accessible cheaper
products
you know so so um narita airport it's
over 40 years old it's
they like to do the traditional way too
fly in and out
very traditional old machines you know
they don't really update them old
airplanes
well before the pandemic they were
handling 40 million passengers and
000 flights a year but now during the
pandemic
this farmer is like it's been great man
like the air quality is getting better
like they're it's not as noisy
not so much like air traffic so
it's been he's been chilling but he ha
he's always
constantly going into court battling
this airport and then
they seem to have won an important case
against the farmer but we don't know if
they're going to force him like a victim
or i feel like the airport's eventually
gonna win oh yeah cause of the money
if he dies it's over right yeah who's he
gonna pass it down to does he have to
crash a plane into the farm
at farmland [ __ ]
that's a good idea though if you're that
fair no if they do
that if they do that the farmer wins no
yeah because of it then they just he
gets the title if you destroy the top
soil yeah that's what that's what he
really cares about oh yeah yeah yeah no
more topsoil
damn that's monsanto style but then he
says that sometimes they
like he'll see like black suvs parking
near his farm and like
just like watching he should just shoot
[ __ ] fertilizer at him
get out of here but he continues to
farm for his 400 customers that is
relying on him for his fresh produce
would you guys
fight that long because i think no
i'm really petty so maybe i will i will
um
i want to i like relaxing same i'll give
him an outrageous price
yes if he got offered 1.6 million that's
not enough if that's what they offer
then i'm gonna double i'll be like i'll
be like 50 mil
boom he was saying that that 1.6 mil it
or
it was 180 million yen but that's 150
years worth of
farmers wages but he says i'm not
interested in money years
they don't make [ __ ] dude how many years
did he own oh that his family
his family has owned the farm for a
hundred years yeah i don't feel like i
could they don't make
[ __ ] dude you think in town it's like
hey we're
you're a farmer we're at he's like uh
it's the airport farm
he has to go like one guy through a
whole bunch of tunnels
and he's constantly getting uh he's
getting not
necessarily harassed but like he's
constantly getting bothered for
identification even though they know who
he is that's why i wouldn't take 1.6 mil
because i'd be like no no you guys
[ __ ] with me too much
yeah that's why i'll say sure i'll sell
it to you but it's 50 mil
what if you take 1.6 and you just
negotiate where you get a family plaque
there
so you know the history you have to go
visit okay i'm going to go into the
negotiation room i don't want to [ __ ]
plaque
why because i want money i want the 50
million dollars bart's like we'll sell
you our house
but you put a plaque here it has me
taika and jio no
he he's out of the negotiations i'm
relaxing like whatever we'll [ __ ]
bury the place people know
like yeah with the wolf like [ __ ]
this big what's the option he's trying
to fight for
that this airport is making i would
calculate
like adding a new landing strip or more
shopping in the airport right i would
calculate
because of my land they're going to be
making let's say 100 mil
right so then within the next 10 years
or probably way more than well then then
50 million sounds good yeah and then
that's all coming to the negotiation
table like yo
this is okay you're going to negotiate
for us yup so he also takes japanese
so it works i want bart to negotiate for
me you can have him you're gonna get a
bart's negotiation is
i want a statue of me and it's gonna be
this big airport
and they're like like here's your statue
sir no bart starts at
plaque and then it ends with doormat
with your family picture on it and
people are walking on it every day
[ __ ] wiping their feet on it oh man
but he's like yeah at least we're there
and it's a candid picture too where
we're like
all [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you